hey all you phenom zijn filibusters
coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 56 so I
cheated a lot in high school and college
usually was by the old classic method of
just looking over at the person's test
next you sometimes I write information
on a little crib sheet or save stuff in
my trusty ti-83 calculator and I do
vaguely remember trying to steal tests
from a teacher's desk once though I
can't be sure if that was only something
I saw in a movie oh thank you mostly I
cheated on tests or homework never
really on term papers I never plagiarize
for some reason getting caught
plagiarizing seem like the worst thing
that could happen to you when I was in
school although for my very final paper
in college I did hand in my roommates
history essay on the Nazis I was taking
a sociology class but you know the Nazis
they really cover a lot of ground I
haven't spent a lot of time thinking
about it since really I didn't think
about it much at the time I suppose I
just knew that the old adage cheaters
never win was just a crock --is--
because I cheated and won now I don't
encourage cheating of course not but it
is a part of my life and I think it's
worth exploring a little bit more
cheating is simply acting dishonestly to
gain an advantage in high school what
was the advantage that I wanted or
thought I needed to gain well when I
went to school the primary purpose of
school was not to learn although that
was not a negative upshot the primary
purpose of school was to get good grades
so we could get into a good college so
when we graduated we'd have the
empirically proven advantage of getting
a good job so we wouldn't be degenerate
the motivational structures were
achingly clear the point was to get good
grades not to get good grades honestly
the only reason to act honestly was that
you wouldn't run the risk of getting
caught cheating which would after all
injure your ability to achieve the goal
in the first place the ironic thing is
that so pressured as we were to achieve
the
grade and the good college and the good
job we saw no qualms in cheating to get
there and having cheated to get there
and having got there with the good job
in a world where cheating as much much
less viable we all have work ethics that
are absolute and we're all that much
closer to being degenerate sometimes I
laugh about that randomly on the subway
or just walking down the street and
people look at me strangely but it's
just the kind of joke that's too damn
funny
to keep it you know can you blame me for
cheating of course you can I cheated and
I'm not the only one a Rutgers study
from way back in 1997 before there were
SAT prep courses that surveyed 1,800
people in nine state universities found
that 3/4 3 out of 4 people cheated on
exams or written assignments and you can
blame them too but the epidemic of
cheating in school in science in sports
is something that we're all on the hook
for and let's never buy into that
bullshit that I am the only one
responsible for my actions or you are
the only one responsible for yours we're
all responsible for one another in each
act of cheating we perform a
cost-benefit analysis think of the
16-year old me taking that physics exam
if I get caught I may get a bad grade on
the tests a call home to my parents or
detention
well detention is nothing a call home to
my parents sucks but they only want me
to get good grades and a bad grade sucks
too but my teachers and my school want
what my parents want for me to succeed
if I don't get caught I'll have
successfully bypass work that I didn't
want to do in the first place and I'll
have moved further down that
motivational yellow brick road that
leads to a good career and of course us
or you know the upper-middle class
version of us which is I don't know a
fondue maker just watch madness cheating
is an activity latent in all nature as a
way for organisms to gain an advantage
without incurring the cost of effort I
was reading recently that Pseudomonas
bacteria exploit the Goods generated by
cooperating bacteria without sharing in
the production those bastards fish cheap
primates cheap we cheat on tests on
diets on the Tour de France on spouses
ah but there's the rub infidelity is a
kind of cheating that it's impossible
for us to justify right because it's the
abuse of relationships for personal gain
it's easy for us to feel why it's wrong
to exploit another person especially
someone so invested in us as a
significant other for a cheap thrill as
we move out of the educational system
with it's painfully mistaken
motivational cues it becomes clear to us
it became clear to me that this is the
foundation of all kinds of cheating the
leveraging of another person for
personal better and we all know how
levers work as someone moves up someone
else somewhere perhaps by subtle
conduits gets pushed down this I suspect
is the true meaning of that adage
cheaters never win even if you get away
with it
out there even if you're not aware of
the consequences of your actions you can
never truly get away with it in here but
for the sake of honesty and a less
rainbow sunset everything is lovely and
will work out ending to this vlog let me
ask you cheater
have you gotten away with it if I don't
not just my dad
this work is making me feel so damn easy
hey everyone sorry the vlog is so late
this week the reason is that I was sent
up to Boston earlier this week to cover
the Marathon bombing story a surreal and
unexpected week to be sure so thanks for
sticking with me hopefully we can get
back on schedule for next week and I'll
see you next time